yo what's up guys marques Brownlee here
from mkbhd and welcome to another tech
related video this is going to be tech
channel of the week number two the comp
you geeks and their annotation will be
floating above my head if you're sorry
if you're not one of the first to watch
this video you'll see so let me just
pull up their channel real quick and so
this is the Compu weeks youtube channel
first thing you'll notice when you go to
their channel is a hardware video but um
on the left hand side you'll see last
sign in was two hours ago they do sign
in quite frequently and um you know they
do produce a ton of videos they make a
lot of hardware and software videos and
I'll get more into that in a second so
they have 481 subscribers 7,000 more
than 7,000 channel views and if we
scroll down a little here they update
their total video count which is now at
more than 7,000 or 27,000 approaching
30,000 and they are from Ireland and
you'll notice I keep saying they as I
describe this YouTube channel and that
is because this YouTube channel is run
by two people known as alpha or alpha
geek and beta geek and alpha will do all
the Mac os10 tutorials and beta geek
does all the Windows tutorials so
Windows Vista tutorials Mac os10
tutorials and that together combined
makes it makes for a very good channel
so you'll see obviously there's two
people running this channel so there's
more than a hundred videos even with a
few having been deleted and if you do go
to their most viewed videos you'll
you'll see instantly I'm uploading a
video right now so my internet
connection is a bit laggy but yeah there
are Windows tutorials up here and there
are there are Mac os10 tutorials up here
so again this channel is the tech
channel of the week because a lot of
helpful and useful tech related
information comes out of this channel
pretty much every 2 or 3 days there's a
new video uploaded and he recently
started getting into more hardware
videos like me he did a case review for
iFrogz that he uploaded today so yeah if
you guys want to go support this channel
go check out this channel if you want to
subscribe they do have a lot of videos
and you'll definitely get your week's
worth of technology information if you
do subscribe to these guys so yeah
that thanks for watching this tech
channel the week number 2 episode again
your best chance of qualifying for the
tech channel of the week is it sorry if
you're a subscriber and if I everytime
someone subscribes to my channel I go
ahead and check out their YouTube page
maybe they're another tech reviewer like
me so yeah your best chance is just not
asking but if you do produce quality
tech videos and you are a subscriber
then you do qualify and I'm definitely
gonna look at your channel so thanks for
checking out this tech channel to week
number two check out their channel right
above me and that's basically it so
thanks for watching peace